The kitchen of misery isn't about cooking. It's about sabotage. You are what you eat. Or so they
say. But if you want to be a masterpiece of self-inflicted wretchedness, you must eat like
a man who has already surrendered. The process begins with breakfast. Not oatmeal, not eggs,
not anything that might trick your body into thinking it's alive. No, you need something
with a shelf life longer than your current relationship. Something that promises energy,
but delivers only a sugar spike so sharp it crashes by 10.30, leaving you adrift in a sea
of your own exhaustion. Protein, that's for people who believe in recovery. You want guilt. You want
the slow creeping realization that you've already failed today. And then there's the way you eat it.
No table. No chairs. No ceremony. Just the mechanical act of shoveling calories into your mouth while
standing over the sink. Or better yet, hunched in the dark glow of a laptop screen. The light
is just enough to see the keyboard. Not enough to see the food. No plates. No forks. Just the quiet,
relentless intake of something that tastes like regret and artificial flavor. Every meal must be a crime
against your own body. Salty enough to make your fingers swell. Just a little. The physical discomfort
is a reminder. You're doing this on purpose. The bloating is your baseline. The irritation is your
companion. And when the midday slump hits, when your body begs for something clean, something real,
you don't listen. You reach for the high fructose delivery system. You feed the crash. You watch as
your energy dissolves into static. This is how you eliminate the possibility of a good mood.
It's simple, really. When your gut is actively protesting your life choices, when every bite feels
like a betrayal. Optimism becomes a luxury you can no longer afford. And if by some cruel twist of fate
you find yourself craving an apple something fresh, something whole you don't give in, you don't even
hesitate. You watch a 15-second ad for a double bacon cheeseburger instead. You recalibrate your
desires. You remind yourself what you truly want. Because misery isn't just about what you eat.
It's about what you deny yourself. And in the kitchen of the truly wretched, denial is the main course.